life banter road traders and bigger
sanctions for companies guilty of
abusing the markets five years on from
the lehman brothers collapse and after a
wave of scandals like libor where banks
manipulated lending rates the eu wants
to get even tougher on the financial
industry for arlene mccarthy if eu
countries are serious about putting
public confidence back into financial
markets then they must enforce strict
rules to meps backed in a vote on
tuesday we're now seeing rumors in the
press about perhaps uh market
manipulation of oil prices of gas prices
of foreign exchange markets so we're
going for higher fines
we're going for the option of criminal
sanctions people can go to jail for this
kind of abuse so really it's a tougher
regime
tougher sanctions tougher penalties and
i think it will be a strong deterrent
the european eel is under threat
pollution over fishing the environment
all key factors have led to staggering
95 decrease in eel stocks over the past
three decades scientists warned that
extinction may not be far away
mep say the current eel re-management
plan is failed and are calling for new
legislation there's no other fish stock
in the european union i would say that
is in such a bad shape as the european
eel and it's also a stock that is shared
by all the european the european
countries the old ill recovery plan has
not worked so we need something new on
the table we need something urgently and
this is what we've asked the commission
to